トゥルル
もっやもや〜
寒いけど...俺は外で撮るぞ....！
ウ‘‘ゥ‘‘ゥ‘‘ェ‘‘‼
寒っっっ！！
こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
静岡から東京に車で向かってるんですけども
家を出たのが確か３時半ぐらいかな...
夜中の３時半くらいに寝ずに来て
今横浜のサービスエリアくらいまで飛ばして来ました
で、高速道路っていうのはねほんとに危ないです
あの車のスピードも速いし、
ミスるともう一発で多分死んじゃうんで
人の飛び出しとかはないんですけど非常に危険です
高速道路の運転で、まじで僕みたいに徹夜でね
このまま朝東京に行くんで、危険なのが、、
高速道路とかまっすぐ運転してるだけだからすごい眠くなっちゃうんですよね
で僕も現に眠かったですここまで来るとき
眠かったんですけども
居眠り運転が一番危ない！
でも僕は！
事故っていない....！
一回も居眠りしたことないです（当たり前じゃい！）
車を持ってる方もいると思うんですけども
この先皆さんも車に乗ることがあると思うんですよ！
そんな皆さんの為に僕が今回独自に編み出した
静岡と東京を行き来する間に編み出した...
絶対寝ない方法を皆さんに教えようと思います
パチッッ
では、、、イこう
いいねぇ、、僕サービスエリア好きなんすよ
６時くらいからね大体もう...天気が
良く...は、俺の車じゃない
６時くらいからもう今結構明るくなってきますね...
飲み物も食べ物も一切買わないです
少しでも腹をふくれる要因を減らすために常に腹は空かしておきましょう
さっそく車にrade onします
まったく動画と関係ないんですけども
足元がクソださいです
っっしゃぁぁああ！
まずポイントがいくつかありまして
ひとまずですね
ひとまず...
モヤーーン
は？
、、おし...ついた！
ひとまず、エアコンは切ります
暖かいとねむくなるので一切そういうのもナシで！
眠気にいざなわれてしまうのでそういうのも一切ナシでいきます
じゃあイくぜっっっ！！！
ガンガンとぼｓ、、
飛ばｓ、、じゃダメですよ
安全運転で行きましょうね
ほんとに、まじで
流れにのれよ、、俺！
イけるか...イかしてください....！頼む
しばらくは大丈夫なんですよね
走り出しは基本的に眠くなることはないので
こっからでございます
ファァ↑(大大大あくび)
モヤッッッ
いだい...
ア‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァン///‘‘ｗｗｗｗ
ア‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ア‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ン///ｗｗｗｗ
ア‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ア‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ア‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ｗｗｗｗ
ウェア！！！
ぁあ！ぁあ！ぁあ！ぁあ！ぁあ！ぁあ！ぁあ！ぁあ！ぁあん//
ア‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ァ‘‘ｗｗｗｗ
モヤシ顔
立てば芍薬座れば牡丹～～～～♪
歩く姿は百合の花～～～～♪
誰もが羨む完璧JK！！！！
おぃ！おぃ！おぃ！おi...
ぶはぁあ、ハァハァハァハァハァハァハァハァ
ハァ、、ハァ//、、、
ハァ//、、、、
危ない、、、
まぁ寝れば一番安全なんですけども、、、
僕みたいにやむをえず眠い時にも車にのんなきゃいけないことがあると思います
特に高速道路ではほんと寝ることがもう命取りになるので絶対寝ちゃいけないと思っています
もう結構僕が編み出したやつまじであの...寝ないんで
寝不足の時に高速道路を乗るよーって人はぜひ試してみて下さい！
不審者扱いされたら....
ごめん